uh all right we're gonna make a turn now
uh for many families uh with kids it's
been a summer of baseball camps of
travel leagues of backyard games but for
some young fans with disabilities the
ballpark is coming to life for the very
first time thanks to a non-profit called
the called the beautiful lives project
the beautiful lives project it's
traveling all across the country
offering those fans the opportunity to
actively participate on the field and
off scott mcfarland traveled to york
pennsylvania where things were in full
swing
how far can you throw it
ethan breiner wants to be a catcher just
like his big brother
that is a wide curveball they're already
working on ethan's home run celebration
breiner lives near york pennsylvania and
was among the first to arrive when the
york revolution minor league baseball
team donated their field for the day are
you good
yes
i'm awesome
for adults and children who say they're
often left out when local towns and
communities organize sports leagues and
events
carter hutchinson born 16 weeks
premature with cerebral palsy took
swings in the batting cage and tosses in
the outfield his mom says carter suffers
chronic pain and breathing struggles but
always has a sparkle in his eye when he
talks baseball i can't imagine not
having baseball i love it so much it
brings us so much joy
carter is an 11 year old encyclopedia of
the sport who knows every batting
average home run total in every world
series champ since the 1970s who won the
world series in 2000. the yankees how
about in 1990
the reds from town to town beautiful
lives project finds and invites the
local kids and adults with disabilities
to play
and it's often the local minor league
baseball players leading the drills
these events were dreamt up and
organized by a young man who now brings
them all across the country in the
summer
a man who's also seizing his own
opportunity
inside the press box thank you for
coming out bryce weiler of illinois
who's put together 20 stops this year
from boston to minneapolis to here in
york bryce is blind and discovered few
people think to organize events like
this so he does it they're able to see
how important it is to surround yourself
with people and friends who believe in
you and weiler is not stopping there
wants to get it over into the zone and
not put another runner on base he's
begun broadcasting calling nearly 150
games so far he scouts out the teams he
talks with the managers even plays catch
with some of the players or coaches
before the game he's only been thrown
out four times he has speed at the top
and follows his play-by-play partner's
lead and words to chime in when
something unexpected or important
happens he's just missing up and low he
just can't get it in the middle it's an
effort to break more boundaries to
convince others with vision impairments
to consider pursuing it
as for his non-profit it's a bigger hit
than imagine
61 people showed up for the event in
york who at no cost enjoyed the day of
their lives and where ethan had a chance
to emulate and bond with his hero
big brother dustin he takes good care of
me and i love him all my life
bring me cheers
for cbs mornings i'm scott mcfarland in
york pennsylvania
i love ethan talking about his brother
he takes care of me i love him all my
life that's why i think a big brother is
so cool and how about how about uh the
guy who started it all where he said
bryce
where he said that no one was doing it
so i'll just do it myself yeah sure it's
called innovation i love that baseball's
connecting with that whole group of
people as well i mean you wouldn't think
they'd want to do it but they love it
it's a great story
thank you very much